can i get a drum roll please
she's definitely taken definitely
okay mal we know you were deeply in love
with king ben at the end of descendants
3
but would you have gone on to have kids
with him or would your vk roots have
pulled you over to hairy hook
we know the two of you have serious
chemistry in the movie and in real life
too of course
regardless of which guide you choose in
the end one thing's for sure there's no
keeping that purple hair down
your kid is sure to inherit that what
would the next generation of bks look
like in descendants 4.
we're imagining all the key couples kids
as well as other pairings that might
have gotten together
keep watching to the end to discover
which unlikely couple would have an
awesome looking kid
plenty of fans have been shipping them
mal and ben we're starting with the
biggest vk ak alliance in the whole
franchise
and we can just imagine mal and ben with
an adorable daughter
finn has hazel eyes and mal of course
has striking green eyes
so it's pretty much a given that their
little girl would follow in those
footsteps
as for hair color we can't help to think
that this little one will take after her
mom
of course mal has gone through different
shades from blonde to blue but purple is
her
signature hue i couldn't be prouder or
happier to call me my queen
mal and terry there's no denying there's
chemistry between mal and harry hook
and with dove cameron and thomas doherty
dating in real life
let's have a little fun with art
imitating life what if mal and ben broke
up
and mal and harry had a kid we see these
two vks having a son
and he'd be a mix of his parents key
looks i believe i deserve some
compensation with his dad's dark hair
this little boy would represent his mom
with an awesome purple streak right
through it of course he'd wear a guy
liner
just like his dad and his grandad hades
audrey and harry when it comes to harry
mao might have competition
on her hands from ak turns vk turned aka
again audrey
after all audrey and harry got a little
friendly at the end of d3
imagine if they had a little girl we'd
love to see audrey's spell
pink and blue streaks in mini-me form on
her daughter but what would she inherit
from her pirate father
his love of ruffle collars and leather
of course
evie and doug evie's blue hair is her
signature look so we can't imagine her
daughter with doug
having anything other than blueberry lox
given that doug grew out its hair to
epic lengths in d3
we are certain that their kid would have
a following mane too
but this little girl would inherit
something special from her daddy
gorgeous green eyes how cute would it be
for mal and evie's daughters to be green
eye twins
she'd be super well dressed in blue and
red too thanks to her fashion designer
mother
evie and carlos so many descendants fans
shipped evie and carlos so we have to
imagine what their little boy would look
like
don't you think carlos's white hair
would look amazing with evie's blue hair
showing through with the roots we'd also
love to see carlos's freckles being
inherited by his son with evie
with their dark brown eyes being passed
on to their boy he'd be
totally striking jane and carlos
carlos was actually head over heels in
love with jane of course
so the likelihood is that this couple
would go to the distance
we see them having a little girl who
would dress in lacy blue outfits just
like her mom
their daughter would inherit jane's
beautiful blue eyes too she'd have her
daddy's hair though
just imagine carlos white locks on a
girl
all the way down to her waist truly
stunning
you just gotta man up and while you're
at it
scratch my butt jay and lonnie
there's no way jay and lonnie's children
wouldn't have long dark locks
just look at their parents we could see
this couple having a boy
and a girl and these siblings would have
matching manes
as their dad has proven boys can rock
man buns
so they could wear their hair in
matching styles and they would totally
rock red leather outfits to represent
their grandfather jafar
dizzy and squeaky squeaky would likely
have twins but rather than boys
he'd have identical girls and we'd love
to see him having those twins with
fellow vk dizzy tremaine
but how would they tell their kids apart
well that'd be thanks to their mom's
mad hairdressing skills oh what is this
bored to death pink just like dizzy's
multi-colored space buns these girls
would have their own cool style
but one would have blue and green
streaks while the other would have red
and yellow streaks
that's against the bright blonde hair
they'd have inherited from their dad
celia and squirmy as for squirmy his son
would rock a pair of black framed
eyeglasses like a cool geek
we're matching squirmy with the other d3
vk
celia and we could see her curly red
hair being passed on to her little boy
combined with his dad's red beanie hand
me down this kid would be rocking the
red look all over
uma and ben are you shipping ben and uma
if so you're going to love what their
kid would look like
we can't imagine their son with anything
other than aqua blue plaits
tied back and like his dad he'd wear a
royal blue shirt
he'd be one amazing mashup of a pirate
and a king
the rest of the bks better beware this
boy is ready to rule auradon
and the isle and that's a wrap which
couple having kids are you shipping the
most
let us know in the comments we can't
wait for you and kristoff to get married
anna we know that he keeps trying to
propose to you and frozen too
and once he finally does we know you'll
say yes the two of you are still young
but eventually you'll probably start a
family
and anna you're going to be such a great
mom we hope that one day we get to see
your adorable kids building a snowman
with olaf
have you ever wondered what some of the
disney princesses would be like as
parents
keep watching to find out what anna and
kristoff's children would look like and
whether or not they'll have powers like
their aunt elsa
rapunzel we know that rapunzel marries
eugene because we saw their wedding and
tangled ever after
these two are going to be the most
loving parents ever
they both had tough childhoods eugene
grew up in an orphanage so he didn't get
a lot of attention
rapunzel of course grew up with mother
gothel and gothel only pretended to love
rapunzel to manipulate her
rapunzel would never do that to her kids
she would also never lock them away
because she hated living in her tower
she would make sure they had tons of
adventures eugene
loves being rich so he would spoil them
run rapunzel would
also teach them to be kind and to never
judge a book by its cover
some of their most loyal friends were
really scary looking
rapunzel would encourage her kids to
have lots of hobbies
just like she did rapunzel and eugene
would also have the
cutest kids these two are just so cute
together
of course it will rub off on their kids
we love this fan art from deviant artist
locote look how happy rapunzel and
eugene look as parents
it's so sweet tiana while rapunzel might
be a free-spirited mom princess tiana
would have a different approach to
parenting
tiana was raised to be a hard worker and
she would absolutely raise her kids the
same way
her children would be doing chores from
a very early age
she would want them to learn to take
care of themselves she would love them
dearly but she would make sure they
fought their own battles
she would help them set goals and learn
how to achieve them
now her husband would have a totally
different approach naveen would be the
fun parent who lets the kids eat ice
cream for dinner
you would stop tiana from being too
serious and we bet those kids would turn
into
awesome cooks check out this adorable
fan art from deviant artist
avatha101 tiana would definitely have
her kids in the kitchen
helping when they're little it's a great
way to bond with them
mal we know mal might not be one of the
classic disney princesses but she was
the daughter of a fairy queen
and she is going to be the queen of
auradon like tiana and naveen mal and
ben might have some different approaches
to parenting
mal is going to be a very different
parent than maleficent easy-peasy she's
going to make sure her kids
always know that she loves them and
she'll probably teach them how to get
into some trouble
mal won't want her kids to be too
spoiled since they're growing up in
auradon
she knows that her tough life on the
isle is what made her strong
so she'll also encourage her kids to
visit the isle weekly
mal will make sure that her youngsters
know where their mom came from
ben on the other hand will want to spoil
his kids he'll be such a fun dad and
their children are going to be the best
dressed kids in auradon with evie as
their aunt
check out our og picture of mal then and
their oldest daughter
what an adorable family jasmine
we totally love the new version of
aladdin princess jasmine is so awesome
in it
jasmine would be such a great mom even
though she's busy ruling agrabah
she would still make plenty of time for
her kids she would teach them how to be
strong
caring rulers she wouldn't lock them
away in the palace because she knows how
lonely that can be
aladdin would probably do most of the
boring parenting stuff like diapers and
snacks
jasmine is a busy ruler after all these
two would take their kids on family
trips on the magic carpet
jasmine would make sure that raja the
tiger protects her kids
and abu would make sure that they got
into a little trouble check out this
sweet fan art from
dark matter nova on deviantart jasmine
would sing to her kids
just like her mom saying to her anna
we're starting to notice a trend with
the princesses who are locked away from
the world
that brings us to anna from frozen she
and kristoff make such a cute couple and
they're going to be amazing parents
anna will be such a fun mom she'll never
want her kids to be as bored as she was
growing up
she'll play with them all the time her
kids will grow up having their mom as
their best friend
they'll know that they can come to her
with anything because ana's got her
emotions under rats
kristoff will be a super hands-on dad he
didn't have a family when he was growing
up so he'll be super loving
one of ana's daughters will probably
take after aunt elsa
and develop some super cool powers of
her own but
this time elsa will be there to teach
her how to control them
we love this precious drawing from
deviantartist nightlight
which disney princess would you want as
a parent let us know
in the comment section below hey now how
would you feel if a new batch of kids
joined you in descendants 4.
sure you might be stoked to meet your
little brother but how would you feel
about meeting the daughter of an
ice queen we mean she could totally come
after your crown
now that the barrier is gone forever
you'll be dealing with the qualms of vks
and aks alike
some of these new arrivals will help you
keep the peace but
some will cause all kinds of trouble are
you ready for the challenge mal
we'd love to see more references to
disney characters we adore in
descendants 4.
so we've picked out 10 new characters
and cast the perfect disney stars to
play them
keep watching to discover who would play
elsa's daughter and why she would pose a
threat to auradon
tiana's daughter in descendants 3 we got
to meet the villain from the princess
and the frog dr facilier and his
daughter celia
so we're crying out for an ak from this
2009 movie
and we need that to be tiana's daughter
we already know that tiana exists
in the descendants universe she pops up
in the second movie
look real close at the balcony during
ben's royal cotillion
tiana is up there along with prince
naveen ariel is there too
but more on her later we know all about
tiana's story but what about her
daughters
we're sure she'd love to cook just like
her mom and she'd love jazz music just
like her dad
but which actor would play tiana's
daughter without putting a stain
on her name we think zendaya would be
perfect for the part
she loves music obviously and anyone
who's visited zendaya's website
knows that she's a magician in the
kitchen she shared videos of herself
cooking up a storm with her family in a
segment called cooking with the colemans
she's a disney channel alum too having
starred in shake it up
and of course casey undercover we would
love to see zendaya sporting her
mother's colors while attending auradon
prep
so that's the first of our new aks now
let's meet our
first new vk anthony tremaine dizzy
tremaine was one of the lucky four vks
to get an invite to auradon in
descendants 3
and we'd love to meet more of the
tremaine family specifically
anthony tremaine he's anastasia's son
which makes him cousins with dizzy and
step cousins with chad charming
anthony already exists in the
descendants world having featured in
melissa de la cruz's novels
he's described as tall and elegant with
dark hair swept off his forehead
in fact he's so handsome he reminds mal
of ben he's not quite so beautiful on
the inside though
anthony acts like he's of noble blood
and even tries to get people to call him
lord tremaine given that chad is pretty
arrogant too
we'd love to see how these two would
interact would they be
rivals or become besties and who would
play anthony
we think ross lynch would be perfect for
the role
he's got the dark hair and the good
looks too the austin and alley star
could totally pull off being gorgeous
and conceited jenny gothel sticking with
bks how about another character that's
rotten to the core
just like anthony tremaine mother
gothel's daughter ginny
also appears in the descendants novels
they're both villain kids that refuse to
join the anti-heroes club that's the
secret organization of vk's who were
drawn to good
more than evil so it would be
interesting to see how she would act now
that the barrier to the isle is down for
good
and what would happen between her and
mal after all in the novel returned to
the isle of the lost
ginny helped mad maddie push malin to
crocodile infested waters
she also ransacked maleficent's
apartment after mao's mom was
turned into a lizard and stole her capes
she could certainly cause havoc for
mal and maleficent would be out for
revenge
and we think olivia rodrigo could step
into those shoes
perfectly the disney alum who starred in
bizarre bark can certainly throw
a steely stare anyone's way ruby
if we have a vk from tangled then we
certainly need an ak from the same film
so that's where ruby comes in fans of
the descendants wicked world animated
shorts will recognize rapunzel's
daughter ruby
but only by her hair audrey explains
that ruby's hair
leaves 10 minutes after she does in
descendants 4 we'd love to see what this
long-haired character
actually looks and acts like and we'd
love to see olivia holt take the part
this disney channel alum has the perfect
face to play rapunzel's daughter
rapunzel seems to have another daughter
in the descendants universe too
and we think veronica dunn from kc
undercover would be the perfect person
to play ruby's sister
insulin appears in descendants school of
secrets
this web series features a secret camera
in the cafeteria
which spies on auradon prep students
it's revealed that insulin is dating
chad charming
but she discovers that he's also dating
ariel's niece
that love triangle would be fun to
explore in d4
speaking of ariel's niece let's move on
to our next
ak melody ariel is the only disney
princess to have a child in a sequel
movie and her daughter's name is melody
so we would love to see this character
turn from animated form to human form
and d4
in the little mermaid two returned to
the sea malady is only 12 years old
so perhaps she could be part of a
younger generation of kids
after all in d3 the smee twins squeaky
and squirmy
were certainly younger than the main vks
and aks
however we'd love to see selena gomez
take on the role
her looks match up so perfectly with the
dark-haired animated character
so that means melody would need to be
older than 12.
regardless of how old she is melody
would be such a fascinating character to
add into the mix
we're sure uma would have a big part to
play in the movie
so we need to see how their relationship
would play out would they be friends or
would their mother's past keep them
apart
ariel as we've already seen ariel is
certainly part of that descendants world
not only does she have a niece in the
school of secrets online shorts
but she also pops up briefly herself in
the second movie
she's on the balcony at ben's catillion
however it's such a blink and you'll
miss it moment that the movie makers
could definitely get away with recasting
her in d4
we'd love to see ariel get a starring
role and who better to play her than amy
adams
the red-haired celebrity is the right
age for the part she's also got
experience playing a disney princess
and she did play giselle in 2007's
enchanted we think she'd be stoked to
get that role after all
amy has revealed that her favorite
disney song lyric comes from the classic
the little mermaid tune
part of your world we'd also love to see
the voice actress for ursula
whoopi goldberg appear in front of the
camera in d4
ariel versus ursula and d4 uh
yes please aziz there's another
interesting vk ak relationship we'd like
to see in d4
and that's jafar's son versus jasmine
and aladdin's son
of course we all know that jafar's son
is jay but did you know that jasmine and
aladdin had a son called aziz in the
descendants novels
not only that but an actor was cast to
play the part
dejean loyola was reportedly set to
appear in the movies but didn't make the
cut in the end
we'd love to see the canadian actor get
the chance to make it into the fourth
film
aziz's name appears in the descendants
yearbook publication as number 11
on the tourney team that would make him
teammates with jay
and according to the return to the isle
of the lost novel aziz and jay
seem to be friends wouldn't it be
interesting to see that friendship on
screen
we've already seen aziz's parents make a
short appearance in descendants 2
having a meal with mal and ben during a
news item
we'd love to see more of them too haiti
although we're intrigued about aziz and
jay's friendship there's another
relationship we really want to explore
in d4
and that's the relationship between mal
and haiti in descendants 3 we discover
that hades is mal's dad and in the novel
called
return to the isle of the lost we
discover that hades has another child
a boy called haiti in the novel haiti
tells mao she inspired him to become
good haiti is referred to as one of the
younger villains in the anti-heroes club
so we're assuming he's younger than mal
and given that hades left maleficent
when mao was really small
we figure he has a different mom it
would be so awesome to see mal
interacting with a little bro on screen
and we think asher angel would fit the
bill just right
the andy mack actor has disney
credentials so he'd be right at home on
the set of d4
he's six years younger than dove cameron
so it totally works for him to play her
younger brother
honest daughter which other movie gets
us as excited as descendants
uh frozen two of course so we need these
characters
to exist in the same disney verse anna
and elsa
didn't make any appearances in the
descendants film and we know that d4
could fix that by
bringing in ana's daughter to the mix we
could totally see anna having several
kids with kristoff but we'd particularly
like to get to know her eldest daughter
surely she'd be a lot like her
courageous loving mom
and we know just the actress to take on
the role sophie turner
as sansa stark in the game of thrones
sophie has certainly proved her bravery
and those auburn locks would be just
perfect for the part of anna's offspring
we could see ana's daughter hanging out
with lonnie and making sure that
everyone has equal opportunities
at auradon prep elsa's daughter any
movie featuring ana's daughter would
have to feature elsa's daughter too
right we'd love to see these cousins
interacting in d4
and we'd love to see what else's
daughter would actually be like we're
confident that this character would
ruffle quite a few feathers
particularly mal's after all elsa is an
ice queen who's used to being in charge
so we can totally see her daughter
wanting to rule too
and that wouldn't necessarily go down
well with queen mal
elsa walks a fine line between hiro and
villain in frozen
and mal knows all too well what that's
like mal and elsa's daughters would have
plenty in common and that could cause a
major clash
bring it on we say as for who to cast in
the part payton list
gets our vote as emma rossen shows
jessie and the spin-off series bunked
payton's got serious disney channel
history and she looks just right for the
role of the ice queen's offspring
it would be awesome to see peyton and
dove face off on screen
which character would you support so
that's a wrap on the 10 characters we
need in descendants 4.
which character would you most love to
see join the d4 family
be sure to let us know in the comments
you never know where
the bad is going to come from you're
about to become the queen of auradon mal
you and ben are going to make the world
a better place
and one day your daughter is going to
attend auradon prep alongside
evie audrey uma and jane's kids and you
never know where the heroes are gonna
come from
either we really wish we could see what
the next generation of descendants is
going to look like
so we got a little creative well you
know what they say
the poison apple doesn't fall far from
the tree we're still waiting for
descendants 4 to get the green light so
in the meantime we thought it'd be fun
to theorize on possible spin-offs
keep watching to find out what the
future generation of descendants are
going to act
like and look like you won't believe who
mal's daughter is going to be best
friends with
uma's daughter um and her mother ursula
weren't
really close but that's not going to be
the case for uma
and her future daughter if the
descendant's naming trend continues we
think
uma's daughter's name would be ursa just
like her mother
ursa would have strong leadership skills
she would be a great public speaker and
friend
she'd be able to sail a boat from a very
young age and by the time she was a
teenager
ursula would have her own ship and crew
ursula would be one of the best pirates
auradon has ever seen and that's because
she was raised by not one but two
pirates
if you haven't guessed it yet hairy hook
would be ursa's dad
that means that her full name would be
ursa hook the famous granddaughter of
the baddie captain hook
ursa wouldn't carry around a fake hook
like her dad but she'd probably wear a
silver necklace with a hook pendant
ursa would have a great personality she
would be feisty and confident like her
mom
yet sarcastic and witty like her dad she
would easily be one of the most popular
girls at auradon prep but she would
never use her popularity to bully others
at first glance you could never tell
that harry hook was ursus father and
that's because she would look exactly
like her mom
ursa would have long curly brown hair
with aqua tips
she'd have the same skin tone as her mom
and big brown eyes too
she would make her mom proud by sporting
the color aqua but pay homage to her dad
by always wearing a black leather jacket
ursa would be one of the most powerful
vks in auradon she would inherit all of
her mom's powers
uma would eventually give ursa her
seashell necklace and
uma and ursa would turn into cecelia's
and go for long swims under the sea
despite being raised by two vks ursa
would never refer to herself as the bad
guy but that's not to say that she
hasn't partaken in some mischievous
behavior
ursa would be best friends with gil's
daughter who would also be a pirate what
do you think of the name ursa
tell us what you'd name uma's daughter
in the comments carlos's daughter
villains don't make the best parents but
they make fantastic grandparents
carlos's mom carella deville wasn't
exactly nice to him when he was growing
up
but she made up for that by being a
fantastic grandmother to ella deville
we think ella would be a great name for
carlos and jane's daughter
after all it pays homage to both cruella
and cinderella
and since jane's mom the fairy godmother
was first introduced in the disney movie
cinderella it just makes sense if the
shoe fits right
ella would be the sweetest girl in
auradon she would learn the meaning of
true friendship from her dad and she
would be a total animal lover too
dude the dog would eventually have
puppies and ella would keep the runt of
the litter and
name her dudette just like jane ella
would be
super organized she'd planned the school
dances and she'd be coined the auradon
party planner
ella would be incredibly intelligent
she'd be her graduating classes
valedictorian and she'd become a total
tech whiz
thanks to her dad ella would take from
jane's side of the family
like boyfriend and girlfriend we can
hold hands instead of slugging each
other all the time
she'd have the same long brown hair and
bright blue eyes as her mom
but she wouldn't dress like her mom in
the slightest ella would look like a
total vk
in her black white and red leather
outfits specifically designed by her
aunt evie
unlike jane ella would be raised around
magic her fairy godmother would teach
her
everything she knows and she'd even be
allowed to use her wand
despite looking like a total villain
ella would be super sweet and caring
she would never practice black magic and
would defend auradon in the blink of an
eye
she'd be just as brave and honest as her
parents ella would love
school and one day dream of becoming the
headmistress
of ardan prep carlos and jane's girl
would be best friends with jay's
daughter they would go on wild
adventures together and literally be
inseparable what do you guys think of
the name ella
tell us what you would name carlos's
daughter in the comments below
evie's daughter evie's mom the evil
queen
raised her to believe that status beauty
and wealth were the three most important
things a girl could have
you just find yourself a prince with a
big castle
and a mother-in-law wig it didn't take
long for evie to find out that that was
all a lie
which is why that's the last thing she
would ever teach her daughter
in perfect descendants fashion evie
would name her daughter eve
and she'd grow up to be a mixture of
both evie and doug
eve would have the perfect combination
of beauty and brains
she would be one of the most brilliant
students at aradan prep and would
constantly compete with ella to have the
highest grades but on top of being a
total whiz eve would also share her
mother's love for fashion
evie would inspire her to start a
clothing line at 13 years old
which she would name eve's apple and eve
would make suits and gowns for the
students at ardan prep
on top of being a business savvy
go-getter eve would also have a nerdy
side her dad is doug
after all which is why she'd love music
as much as she loves fashion
eve would be a proud member of the
auradon preps marching band and would
play the trumpet just like her dad
despite being a sweet and soft-spoken
person eve would never be a pushover
anyone who tried to make fun of her for
being in the marching band would live to
regret it
eve would be somewhat of a klutz except
for when she's walking down the runway
hi ho evie evil queen's daughter
eve will have the same dark blue hair
color as her mom
she'll be one of the prettiest girls in
school and she'll never go anywhere
without her tiara she'll have her
mother's brown eyes but her dad's poor
eyesight
but she'll opt for contacts instead of
glasses eve will be one of the good guys
and her grandmother the evil queen will
teach her how to use spells
but she'll make sure to filter out the
bad ones eve will be best friends with
dizzy's daughter
izzy who will be an aspiring
photographer they'll spend their days
taking photo shoots and creating new
outfits
tell us what you think of the name eve
in the comments
audrey's daughter audrey may have been
raised by princess aurora and
prince philip but she turned out to be a
total villain and audrey's daughter will
have a mean streak in her too she'll be
the baddest girl in ardon prep but every
now and then she'll show her true colors
despite coming off as a mean girl
audrey's daughter will be one of the
best
friends a person could ever hope for
audrey would continue the descendants
naming trends by naming her daughter
aubry aubry would mimic her mom's
personality and make her proud that when
no one's watching she would let her
guard down and be kind to those closest
to her but unlike her mom aubry wouldn't
throw her princess status in everyone's
face
wearing dresses and going to balls just
wouldn't be her thing aubry would rather
wear comfortable clothes that she can
fence in
aubry would value power and be super
competitive she would be the best
spencer in auradon and pirates would
constantly try to recruit her
aubry would be the daughter of chad and
would have cinderella as a grandmother
but unlike
chad aubry wouldn't be scared of
anything she'd constantly be looking for
the next adventure and
audrey would often scold her daughter
for not being ladylike but that wouldn't
phase her one bit
loyal boyfriend by your side partner in
crime
sidekick aubry would look more like chad
than she would audrey
she would have a pale complexion a light
dusting of freckles and big blue eyes
she would keep her hair short making it
easier to fight the one trait that would
tie audrey and aubry together would be
aubry's vibrant pink hair
audrey and her daughter would fight a
lot but in the end audrey would be super
proud of her for being her own person
aubry wouldn't have any magical powers
of her own but what she'd lack in powers
she'd make up for in skills
just like her parents aubrey is a master
manipulator
she always gets what she wants but that
doesn't mean that she doesn't work hard
to get it
aubrey wouldn't have a lot of friends
due to her pushing people away but
one person would see through her mean
girl act and quickly become
best friends with her mal's daughter
mouse spent most of her life trying to
follow in her mom's footsteps
[Music]
that is until she realized that she
wanted to be her own person
mal's daughter is going to struggle with
the same exact thing
we think mal's daughter would be named
mallory but let us know if you prefer
another name in the comments
being the daughter of the queen and king
of aradon is no small feat
and malory will have some big shoes to
fill from a very young age
despite wanting to make her mom and dad
proud mallory will dream of going on
adventures and will dislike the idea of
one day becoming queen
despite her reluctance to wear the crown
mallory will have excellent leadership
and decision-making skills
she'll have a solution to every problem
and be one of the bravest people in
auradon but when it comes to school
mallory won't be too invested
she'll be naturally street smart and see
mathematics as her own sworn enemy
when need be mallory will be diplomatic
like her father king ben
but she'd much rather be on the front
lines instead of cooped up in an office
mallory will appear super close to her
grandfather hades and he'll teach her
how to bring her powers to the next
level
just like mal mallory will have the
ability to transform into a dragon
she'll be able to cast spells brew
potions and hold her own in a sword
fight
we are all capable of good and bad
malory will be a carbon copy of mal but
ben won't mind one bit she'll have
bright green eyes
dark purple hair and the same complexion
as her mom everyone will recognize the
princess of auradon in a heartbeat
so she'll often use charms to conceal
her appearance believe it or not but
mallory will be best friends with aubry
they'll bond over their parents
expectations of them and become besties
despite their family history and that's
a wrap before you go
tell us who your favorite descendants
couple is and be sure to give their
future kid name
we'd love you to join us at auradon prep
will you come
sign king ben we are so excited that you
get to go to auradon dizzy we totally
fell in love with you in descendants too
you're kind you're smart you're talented
and you're evie's favorite
you deserve so much better than life on
the isle of the lost
evie will take great care of you and you
will be so successful in auradon
just keep an eye on your fellow vks
there are four new villain kids
in descendants 3. do you know which bk
is totally obsessed with all things
shiny
keep watching for the 10 things no one
realized about the new villain kids
not her mother's daughter we meet dizzy
tremaine
in descendants 2 she works at a super
stylish salon
on the isle of the lost dizzy is the
daughter of drizella tremaine one of
cinderella's stepsisters
in cinderella drizella is lazy and mean
but dizzy couldn't be more different
she's super sweet and she is such a hard
worker she runs the salon
and keeps it clean she's also talented
at making accessories like the tiaras
she gave to evie
like father like son two of the new vks
are actually twins
squeaky and squirmy are the sons of mr
smee
smee was the first mate to captain hook
in peter pan
smee was a total doormat to hook he did
whatever the evil captain wanted and he
was so scared of everything
get off you idiots
it's hard to be a pirate if you're timid
squeaky and squirmy are the same way
they're frightened of everything and are
really shy but they have each other at
least
daddy's girl celia facilier is the
doctor of the voodoo master dr facilier
we saw just how powerful dr facilier was
in princess and the frog
some of the vk's don't want to be like
their parents but celia really wants to
make her dad proud
but that doesn't make her a villain
through and through what kind of hustle
you got going on with them
shiny people no hustle i got friends on
the other side
mal totally relates to celia because she
used to want to make her mom proud
even though maleficent was evil wicked
grandmother
we can all agree that lady tremaine was
a terrible stepmother
but she was really good to her daughters
drizella and anastasia
however she has not been a good
grandmother she forces dizzy to do
all the cleaning at the salon and home
lady tremaine dresses nice but dizzy is
often
seen wearing rags and just look at how
tense their relationship is lady
tremaine is
obviously better about losing her
servant's stepdaughter so she takes it
out on dizzy
but that doesn't mean that she doesn't
love dizzy in her own
strange way so excited squeaky and
squirmy may look like they're scared
of everything and who can blame them
they've lived their whole life on the
isle they're really scared of leaving
their dad behind on the isle of the lost
but they're still
super excited they've heard lots of
stories about auradon and they know life
is better there
squeaky and squirmy show us that you can
be scared and excited at the same time
what makes celia really excited keep
watching to find out
southern belle it might seem like celia
is from the isle
after all she lived most of her life
there but celia considers herself
totally southern
she says she's from the south because
that's where her dad's from
dr facilier really lived the louisiana
culture
and that has carried over to his
daughter your heritage doesn't have to
be where you live
and celia really honors that cajun
lifestyle
is your heritage different from where
you live tell us in the comments below
big sister vibes dizzy's mom grew up
with a sister who was close in age
drizella and anastasia mostly got along
but dizzy is an only child
if it wasn't for evie dizzy would be
super lonely she really feels like evie
is her big sister
evie supports her and treats her so
kindly they have each other's backs and
evie is the reason that dizzy gets to go
to auradon
we just love their relationship once
again descendant shows us that you don't
have to be related to be
family biggest fear even though the
twins are excited about auradon they're
really scared
leaving the life you know behind is
terrifying but their biggest fear
is leaving their dead unlike a lot of
vks squeaky and squirmy have a great
relationship with their father
and they are younger than the other vks
they're afraid that they'll never see
their dad again
but carlos reassures them that they will
see mr smee
soon we hope they learn to be a little
less scared
living the dream life on the isle is
pretty rough and while some of the vks
may
enjoy their life or get along with their
parents dizzy isn't one of them
she has dreamed about living her best
life in auradon forever
in fact most of the vks have there's
less crime
and more happiness in auradon dizzy has
been waiting her whole life to get her
chance
i can't believe i get to live with you
in your very own castle
and we just know that she's awesome
enough to succeed with the chance that
evie gives her
money talks it isn't easy to be rich on
the isle there are no castles
and everyone is kind of stuck being poor
so it makes sense that celia is
all about money life for celia is about
business and getting rich
and she isn't afraid to use less than
legal means to achieve it
she's a skilled pickpocketer we just
hope she learns to clean up her act
which of the new vks is your favorite
let us know
in the comments disney's descendants
just dropped another sneak peek at the
new descendants movie
four new villain kids are being chosen
to attend auradon prep
keep watching to find out who these new
vks could be
is every person here really evil do they
deserve to be here
vk day is coming disney has been teasing
us like crazy with all these trailers
for descendants 3 and on may 31st 2019
they're releasing the first music video
it's called
good to be bad but disney channel
decided to give us
even more teasers they released a video
showing us
a bunch of new vks on the isle of the
lost mal evie carlos and jay
are totally the poster children for
turning good and they have a lot of fans
on the aisle
they are choosing four new vks to attend
auradon prep
the latest clip from descendants shows
all the new vks filling out their
applications
they're pumped to be chosen to leave the
isle of the lost
let's break down this teaser trailer to
find all the clues
there are a ton of villain kids on the
aisle and they all look so excited at
the chance to go to auradon
i want to be just like you life on the
isle of the lost is not great
the video clip has a speaker announcing
that vk day is today
it's the deadline for applying to
auradon prep and the decision of who
makes it will be made by the original
four vks
at one point we see a girl with pigtails
filling out her application
she says evie
about halfway through the clip we see a
boy filling out an application
his name is bug he says jay is his
favorite vk
then there's another girl with short
purple hair who just wants to be like
mal mal and the gang are going to
collect the applications and announce
who gets to go to auradon prep
who are the new bks the video clip
doesn't straight up tell us who the new
vks are going to be but there are a lot
of clues in this teaser
let's take a look at our first new vk we
can see a kid filling out an application
his name is bug that doesn't tell us
much
we know that bks tend to have names
really similar to their parents but
let's look at the rest of the clues on
his application
he says he was born on halloween in
2010. he was born in halloweentown
that gives us two different
possibilities for who he is
he could be related to a villain from
the halloweentown movies
these were old disney channel original
movies that started in 1998
but most of our characters in the
descendants franchise are way more
popular than that
the other option is that his parent is
from the nightmare before
christmas disney now owns the rights to
that movie and if you keep reading the
application
it's easy to figure out who bug is
interesting reaction but what does it
mean
he lists his favorite color as burlap
you know
like that stuff that potato bags are
made of well there's one villain made
entirely of burlap
oogie boogie from the nightmare before
christmas and bug
totally sounds like he's related to
oogie boogie now we
aren't sure how a burlap monster had a
human kid but
we aren't here to judge the other two
vks that the clip highlights are girls
and we're pretty sure one of these is
celia
we can't see the face of the girls
filling out the applications but the
reason we think celia gets to go to
auradon
is actually in another teaser in the
mystery trailer there is a scene in
auradon
where guards are fighting something
celia can be seen lurking in the
background
she definitely gets to auradon somehow
and she's going to be playing a huge
role in the movie all
infor donald pay she was acting pretty
shady in that whole trailer
celia is the daughter of dr facilier
from the princess and the frog
we're pretty sure the girl from the new
teaser with purple hair is celia
she looks like she was wearing a wig
she's got mal posters in a room and
every time we see her she's wearing
purple just like mal she probably has
magical
abilities that she inherited we wonder
if celia's story is going to be just
like mal's
she might get sent to auradon by her dad
to do something bad
but decide to be good anyway the last
two new vks have got to be smee's kids
these new characters were announced last
year smee was the loyal assistant of
captain hook
in descendants 3 he has two twin boys
named swarmy and squeaky
these two are great candidates for
auradon we aren't sure their father was
actually a real villain
sure he worked for a bad guy but smee
never seemed evil
he was pretty goofy go on now shoo
shoo and take your arms with you you
won't be ashamed of yourself
and honestly he was a pretty nice dude
he definitely wasn't good at being a
pirate
squeaky and squirmy also appear in the
mystery trailer
they flash through really quickly along
with dizzy tremaine
we see them asleep on a couch in auradon
it sure looks like they fall victim to
the sleeping spell
uh-oh now squeaky and squirmy weren't in
the newest clip with all the isle kids
but we know they end up in auradon
somehow the threat to auradon
mal and the other vks feel really
strongly about giving other villain kids
a chance to go to auradon
and king ben totally supports them
that's why evie gave dizzy
a chance to attend auradon prep at the
end of descendants 2
but even though they are trying to do
good this is going to be where
everything goes wrong
disney is good at keeping us on our toes
but we're pretty sure that vk day
happens at the beginning of the movie
we also think that mal's vision will
happen early on before she heads to the
isle
in the mouse darkness trailer mal and
ben are appearing before auradon
it looks like they might be about to
make an announcement then mal gets her
vision of the sleeping spell and sees
people being turned into stone
we think that they were about to
announce vk day then mel and the other
vks go to the isle to select new
students
we also know that a barrier breach
happens it looks like that is caused by
hades on vk day
oh you shouldn't have come here in the
meet the hades trailer hades tries to
get through the barrier
he pushes past a whole bunch of kids
these kids were waiting on something
from auradon
or maybe they were waving goodbye to the
newest vks this probably happens on vk
day too
so how does hades end up actually
breaking the barrier we have so many
questions
who do you think the newest vks are let
us know in the comments
hit that subscribe button to keep up
with the latest descendants 3 news
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time